As you know,
we were talking about earlier with your,
the way you do yours,
you used to use patrion and now you use your own website after the Sargon of a
cod incident,
which,
you know,
he stepped back away from Patriot now or not.
So no plate on what you think of starting on a mocad.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well it's not even that.
It's a,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well there's so many misconceptions about what happened there and I,
you know,
I tried to clear them up on my podcast,
but yeah,
there's an interesting implication to not taking ads.
I mean,
I,
I think what's happening,
and this is much bigger than even podcasting,
I think,
um,
I'd be interested to know what you feel about this.
You have,
you are the,
the,
the quintessence of the successful ad model in podcasting,
right?
It's like this is you.
It's working fantastically well for you.
And for people like Tim Ferriss and you know,
probably Mark Marin.
I mean there's this,
there's some,
because it was kind of like a winner take all thing happening in the space where
ads are working great.
Um,
and I am a really,
also a highly successful example of the support model is like the PBS model or
the NPR model.
And what's weird is that I can't like that we,
you know,
you and are both surrounded by people who have podcasts to have podcasts and are
asking us for advice about how to succeed and how to monetize.
And like,
I'm not even in a place where I can recommend my model to anyone else.
Right.
Because it's,
it's a very,
you know,
it's,
it's very hit or miss.
I mean,
I had just happened to have developed an audience that will support my work.
And you had developed that audience previously,
ironically enough on youtube.
There's a lot of youtube,
well,
yeah,
just debates and random people putting people,
putting my content on their youtube channels,
but mostly debates,
right?
Yeah.
And as a,
you know,
as an author.
But it would,
I mean it was just the,
the podcast grew and I had this sort of forest choice,
where am I going to go the,
the,
the ad route or,
or not.
And I found that,
I mean I have two things to to say,
you know,
fairly strongly against ads,
but what we're really only one of them applies to me.
And I don't think it applies to you or Tim or,
or anyone else.
I just felt personally I couldn't use ads because of search is what my platform
is and the kinds of topics I'm engaging.
And it just didn't work.
I mean there was nothing high brow enough where I felt like my credibility
wasn't getting subtly undermine.
Bye Bye shilling for it and make it be something that I just legit loved.
And it could have been the Oxford English dictionary,
you know,
like you guys,
he is the best dictionary in the world.
You guys should use it.
I still couldn't do it and I might try it with,
the only thing I took on as a sponsor was audible.
And I did that for some weeks and then it just,
you know,
I love audible but,
but it,
it just felt wrong.
And so I decided to just experiment with a different business model.
And it's working for me,
but it's,
I don't think it can for most people.
And I th I view that as a problem.
And I,
and I,
and the thing that I think is interesting is that there's,
this is much bigger than podcasting.
So you have like,
you have Facebook on the one hand,
which is just a,
a totally free platform where,
where the users don't even realize that they're not the customers,
they're the actual product,
right?
They use is the users are having their attention sold to advertisers and it's
this enormous business.
And on the other end of the digital spectrum,
you have Netflix,
which is just a stark paywall,
right?
And,
um,
there's no way in but to pay the subscription and you know,
that's,
and you know,
Netflix could run ads and get more money if they wanted to,
but they're,
you know,
they're not doing that and presumably won't do that.
And I'm hoping just generally speaking at the digital future,
it looks much more like Netflix and much less like Facebook.
And because I see what ads has ads have done is they've anchored everyone to the
illusion of free.
Everyone expects their digital content for free except in places like Netflix,
right?
So like if when you release a comedy special,
when you really release your next hour and you sell it to neck Netflix,
I would imagine there are very few people in,
in your fan base who are thinking,
well,
fuck Joe Rogan,
why didn't he just put that out on Youtube?
Right?
Why is this on Netflix?
They sort of understand that this piece of content is,
belongs on that shelf,
and that if they want it,
they have to subscribe to Netflix.
Whereas if you did something slightly different,
but you know,
functionally the same if you put it on Vimeo and charge people $5 or whatever,
you know,
Vimeo on demand,
um,
you,
I think you'd get a lot more pain,
right?
Yeah.
People would say,
well fuck you.
You greedy bastard.
Like if you're already doing great,
just release your stuff.
Right?
Yeah.
And I,
I view that as a problem.
It's like,
it's like a psychological problem.
People have been anchored to the ad subsidized model more or less everywhere,
and they expect everything for free.
And in my world,
I'm trying to just continually Brooke that expectation and push people into a
different sense of you get what you pay for.
And so that,
the hybrid model I've created for myself is I'm putting more stuff behind a
paywall,
right?
I mean it.
So this is not just pure sponsorship of,
of otherwise free content,
but I'm a,
I'm very personally,
I'm very uncomfortable with the idea that if someone actually can't afford it,
they can't get access to my content.
So I just tell people,
if you really can't afford the stuff behind my pay wall or you really can't
afford my meditation APP,
just send us an email and we'll give it to you for free.
Right.
So I've heard that.
I was like,
this guy's crazy.
I mean,
it's actually,
it's actually in the pricing in the APP store for my meditation APP.
It's like,
you know,
there's the pricing and then below that there's,
if you can't afford this,
you know,
here's the,
here's the email address.
I think that's fantastic.
And so that's feels free.
Yeah,
I'm splitting it that way,
but I'm raising prices.
So it was like,
it's like a sword because I think everything is too cheap in the,
in the digital space I think.
I think we're anchored to,
I mean,
there are people who will spend $5 a day on a cup of coffee every day for the
rest of their lives.
And yet if you told them this podcast or this app that they,
that they say is incredibly valuable to them is going to cost them $5 a month,
they've,
they feel raped.
Right.
You know,
so it's,
and,
and I completely understand it because I know what it's like to hit a pay wall
and think I can't get my credit card out again.
I'm not going to pay for this.
I'm going to find this information somewhere else.
So we've all been anchored to this thing and you know,
something is going to win in the end.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I think at some point,
it's going to look much more like Netflix or much more like a Facebook.
And I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I'm throwing my lot in with the former,
but you know,
it's,
it really is the wild west.
Well,
the Netflix things different because Netflix has programs that cost a lot of
money to create,
this podcast is very easy.
You're my friend,
I'll call you up.
Hey,
you want to do a podcast?
He come over here.
I mean,
obviously we had to pay for all this equipment,
but other than that,
it's just,
and then with,
and rent and all that stuff.
But other than that,
it just goes up.
Whereas you do a comedy special across hundreds of thousands of dollars.
You have to secure a venue,
you have to hire staff.
I mean,
it's a big deal.
It's,
it's,
that's,
and that's an easy thing in terms of like,
Bang for their buck.
What,
what Netflix,
we'll get out of it.
Um,
if you do a television show,
I mean,
my God,
you,
you need to hire hundreds of people.
There's wardrobe and makeup and set and there's writers and producers and
executives and everyone has to go over the script with a fine tooth comb.
It's incredibly,
incredibly strenuous.
There's a lot going on when you create a television like stranger things or
something like that.
I mean,
you have so much special effects and so to ask for that for free seems to be to
me seems ridiculous.
Well,
yeah,
but except the,
I mean,
so I'm kind of splitting,
again,
I'm running on two tracks here and APP is much more like a television show,
surprisingly then than it is like a podcast.
But even if,
if it's just a podcast,
if you want to build something,
if you want to build a media company like,
like,
like let's say you were,
let's say you were asking for support for this otherwise free Pie podcast,
uh,
people don't know what your aspirations are.
I mean,
maybe you want to start a podcast network,
right?
Maybe you have,
you're trying to build a business that is,
that maybe you have massive payroll expenses that you,
you know,
so the expectation that the product should always be free closes the door to any
of those aspirations if in fact you have them.
And you know,
it's like,
um,
I mean it is,
it's very interesting psychologically because I have,
I've created this network of support from my podcast,
but I see people do calculations that they would never do in a more
transactional space that they were just,
let's say buying my next book,
right?
So like,
um,
for me,
offering a free podcast and then saying,
if you find this valuable,
you can support it,
right?
That,
you know,
from the side of being a creator of that content,
it feels like leaf,
the most transparent interaction possible because a person can listen for free
for as long as they want to just discover how valuable it is and then they can
support it to the degree that they find it valuable.
Whereas if I'm selling you a book,
you can't even read the book before you,
before you buy it.
Right?
You have to make the decision to buy it.
And I'm trying to convince you to buy it because it took me all this time to
write it and,
and uh,
you know,
you're,
it's,
it's transactional
with,
but with a podcast,
people make calculations that they would never make when they're just figuring
out whether they want to buy something.
It's like,
like I'll,
and is really along the lines of what you just described.
People say,
well,
how much has a podcast cost to produce?
Right?
Like I like if I knew what you were spending the money on and what it costs you
to do this podcast will then I would support you.
Right?
But they're never saying how much does it cost to write a book?
And if I knew what you are going to spend the money on once you,
once you were once,
once I bought this book,
then I would know whether or not I wanted to buy it.
You either want the book or you don't.
Right.
So the problem with the support model and this the Po,
the problem with Patriot and everything else is that get engaged as the sort of
the philanthropy charity side of the brain,
right?
And people are worried about what you're going to do and how much it all costs.
Like how much does is my cost?
Right.
You know,
like that,
that's,
that's a question that someone is asking when they're donating,
it wasn't,
and donating.
And the problem there is they're not understanding,
you know,
just the opportunity costs.
Like I,
you know,
I have to decide how to spend my time.
Am I going to spend 90% of my time on a podcast?
Well,
that if,
so that closes the door to virtually everything else I can do.
Right.
So it's,
you know,
it's,
it has to become a viable business.
And so,
I mean,
I,
I've recognized now that I'm,
you know,
to some degree going against the grain of human psychology in asking for
support.
And now I,
now I feel like I'm going to ask much less and I'm going to tell people what the
business model is.
And,
and you know,
and still look and remind them of it,
but I'm personally,
I'm going to go more and more that in the direction of putting stuff behind a
paywall.
And if people want it,
then they can support.
And so it's kind of,
it's sort of Netflix,
the ultimate version of it would be if it were Netflix,
that would also let you get it for free if you really couldn't afford it.
That,
I mean that,
that that's the,
the guilt free business model that I'm,
I'm converging on now.
I like it.
I like how you're thinking and I'd like the ethics involved in it and I think
it's a great thing.
And when you set it on your podcast,
I was shocked,
but it makes sense coming from you.